one pipe can fill a pool one and a half
times or 1.5 times faster than a second
pipe if both pipes are open the pool can
be filled in six hours
if only the slower pipe is open how long
would it take to fill the pool so any of
these things where you have one or more
things that are trying to do some type
of work and not work in the physics
sense but in kind of the everyday sense
they're trying to do a job the pipes are
trying to fill the pool the important
thing to think about is it in terms of
the rate in which the P the pipes can
fill the pool or the guys can mow the
lawn or whatever it might be so let's
think about the two pipes and once you
have the rates you can then add the
rates together so the slower pipe the
slower let me do that in yellow so the
slower pipe slower the slower pipe
what's the rate at which it can fill a
pool well they don't tell us much about
it so let's just say that it it can fill
a pool in T hours or if you wanted to
look the rate at which it could fill the
pool it can do one pool one pool in one
pool in T and T hours and I wanted to
write its rate in terms of T because
that's what we're trying to solve for at
the end how long would it take to fill a
pool it takes it T hours it can do one
pool in T hours this is a rate over here
this is the rate at which the slower
pipe can fill a pool now what about the
faster pipe what about the faster pipe
the faster faster pipe well it tells us
one pipe can fill a pool one and a half
times faster than a second pipe so the
faster pipe can fill a pool one and a
half times faster than a slower pipe so
if this can do one pool in T hours the
faster pool the faster pipe can do one
point five times that it can do one
point five pools one point five pools in
in T hours right in the same amount of
hours it can do one and a half times as
much work or one and a half times as
much of a job it can fill one and a half
pools so how much can they do together
well together let me write
in orange so let's think about it
together two together
what could they do well this if you
let's just imagine that they're working
together forty hours so this can fill
one pool in T hours and this can fill
one and a half pools in T hours you can
add these two things so you get so
together they can do one over T 1 over T
pools per hour pools per hour or one or
pool per hours sometimes the plural and
singular gets a little bit messed up
here but hopefully you get the idea plus
one and a half one and a half over T
pools per hour so together if you add
these two things they're going to be
able to do if you can imagine this guy
can do one pool in two hours this guy
can do one and a half pools in T hours
together they're going to be able to if
you if you let T hours go by together
they're going to be able to do two and a
half pools two and a half pools two and
a half pools in T hours in T hours and
notice the units are the same and you're
really just adding 1 over T plus 1 and
1/2 over T you have the same denominator
so you can just add the numerators 1
plus 1 and half cos 2 and 1/2 and it's
very very very important whenever you're
doing these rate problems is to always
make sure that it's making sense ok yeah
they can do more pools in the same
amount of time we've added the two and I
say that because sometimes when you do
this you're tempted to do the inverse of
these you're tempted to say hours per
pool hours per pool and then when you
add them you will actually get more
hours per pool which is not intuitive
even because if you have two things
working together it shouldn't take more
hours per pool it should you should
beget more pools per hour and so that's
a really important reality check
whenever you're doing one of these rate
problems so anyway if they're working
together they can do 2.5 pools in T
hours and remember the T was just how
long the slower pipe takes to fill one
pool but they also tell us so this is
their rate this is their rate this is
their rate at which they can fill pools
and then they tell us that at that rate
the combined rate together if they if
they
work for six hours if they do if they
work for six hours then they can fill a
pool so you have the rate if you
multiply it by the time if you multiply
it by six hours you should get the
amount of work they've done and once
again this is not work in the physics
sense this is work in the everyday sense
they've the work of filling a pool so if
you get it you get the amount of work
work and I really want to emphasize this
is the non physics if you don't know the
physics definition of work don't worry
about it too much but I don't want
anyone who does know it getting confused
this is really just I guess how much of
a job they can do and so they were able
to fill one pool and the unit's I think
are really convenient here because it
really makes sure you're getting
everything straight
so two-and-a-half pools per hour or two
and a half over T pools per hour times
six hours gives us one pool they give us
the six hours right over there that's
how long it takes to fill one pool and
so now we can solve for T if we divide
both sides if we divide both sides by
well we can divide both sides by six
hours we can divide both sides by six
hours six hours we get on the left-hand
side this cancels out you get 2.5 over T
pool pulls per hours I guess we could
say or pools per hour is one way to
think about it is equal to 1/6 or one
over six pools per hour and I know I'm
adding s s and taking it off s is here
that's where the unit's start to break
down a little bit but I think you see
what I'm doing I'm just making it sound
a little bit better in English and so
you have the same units on both sides so
two-and-a-half over T must be equal to
1/6 so let me write it over here so 2.5
over T must be equal to 1/6 must be
equal I wouldn't do that in that green
color must be equal to 1 over 6 and so
we can multiply we can multiply both
sides by T and multiply both sides by 6
to get rid of the denominators there so
we're going to multiply both sides by
six and multiply both sides by T both
sides by T and both sides by six 6
cancels with six on the right hand side
we are just left with a T T times 1 on
the left hand side this T cancels with
this T 6 times 2 and 1/2 6 times 2 is 12
6 times 1/2 is 3 so 12 plus 3 is 15 so T
is equal to 15 so if you go back over
here you get 15 for this so the slower
pipe can fill one pool in 15 hours one
pool and 15 hours so that answers our
question if the slower pipe is open how
long would it take to fill the pool it
can fill one pool in 15 hours so the
answer is 15 15 hours and we are done